Hello everyone and welcome to the
Toastmasters public speaking webinar
series. We are delighted to have you
join us today for the humor workshop
part one.
My name is Linda Williams and unlike
members of our panel today, I am not a
comedian.
But I do play one on TV.
Not really.
Actually, I'm a training and development
specialist with Toastmasters
International. Thank you so much from
joining us from all around the globe.
Before you meet our moderator and our
panelists, I wanted to take a few
minutes to set the stage for our time
together.
For the majority of the workshop, we'll
be watching a live discussion between
members of our expert panel.
Maybe I should call them our comedy
council.
As we all laugh and learn together
throughout this forum of funny today, we
expect that you might have some
questions.
Please use the Q&A panel on your screen
to submit them and towards the end of
the workshop, we will bring many of your
questions into the conversation.
With so many attendees, however, we
might not be able to get to all of them.
So, we'll do our best and we appreciate
your patience and understanding.
While you will not be able to speak
aloud, we encourage you to use the chat
feature like you're already doing to
continue talking with one another
throughout the workshop.
And we thank you in advance for always
remembering to be polite and courteous
to your fellow attendees.
Also, please keep in mind that our team
will be focusing on answering questions
posted in the Q&A panel, not questions
posted in the chat.
This workshop is being recorded and
everyone will receive an email in a few
days with a link to the recording.
All right, final thing before I hand off
the workshop to our moderator.
The panel has asked me to gauge the
humor level of the audience. Just how
funny do we think we are?
So, if you'd like to, I'm going to ask
you to answer one question using the
polling feature. You'll see it on your
screen in just a moment.
Which of the following statements best
describes you?
I wish I were funnier.
I can't tell if people are laughing with
me or at me.
People tell me I'm funny.
Or I am hilarious.
I'll give you a few more seconds to go
ahead and answer that poll.
I can see the results coming in
and it looks like I wish I were funnier
is taking a little bit of a lead.
In about 3 more seconds and I'm going to
stop the polling.
All right. Let's see our results.
Yes, coming in at 45% of our audience, I
wish I were funnier. Well,
I think you're in the right place.
I chose people tell me I'm funny.
Or wait, is it people tell me I'm funny
looking?
Anyway, I now have the grand honor of
introducing our workshop moderator Mark
Brown.
Mark is originally from Kingston,
Jamaica and he immigrated to the United
States at 18 years old with only $40 in
his pocket and a dream for a better
life.
In 1995,
Mark defeated more than 20,000
contestants from 14 different countries
to win the illustrious title of
Toastmasters International World
Champion of Public Speaking.
Since that day, Mark has delivered more
than 3,500
presentations on five different
continents to more than 1.7
million people.
Please welcome one of the most popular
inspirational speakers in the world, the
fabulous and funny Mark Brown.
Thank you, Linda. Thank you so much. I'm
happy to be here with you and of course
our great panel of experts.
I'm really thrilled today to introduce
our first panelist, Stefan Dyer.
Originally from Canada,
from Costa Rica rather, Stefan is a
banker turned comedian, get that, with
400 plus shows across eight countries
including Peru, Mexico and Malaysia.
In 2017,
after being one of the youngest senior
managers at Scotiabank Toronto, he quit
his lucrative bank job to pursue a
professional career in stand-up comedy.
Since then, he's been on Comedy Central
but Second City, TedX, some of the
world's largest comedy festivals and he
is the co-founder and see and co-CEO of
Malpensando Malpensando, an
award-winning bilingual public speaking
and comedy school in Toronto, Canada.
And he has empowered thousands of people
to become funny and confident speakers.
Welcome, Stefan.
Our second expert today is Veronica
Dangerfield.
Veronica has won numerous awards for her
work as a financial educator
and she talks about a topic that needs
humor. Wow, financial education, go
figure, right? Now, in addition to that,
her current role is of course is a
financial educator. Which is also an
award-winning international speaker, a
published poet and professional
comedian. Now, old folks like me think
Dangerfield doesn't look like him.
Now, we've been told that
her her mesmerizing style will grab your
mind,
ignite your soul, boop, and move you to
be empowered with your money
and then some.
Our third and final panelist today is
Drew Tarvin. A former engineer by
profession, Drew calls himself a humor
engineer in that he's teaching people
how to get better results while having
more fun. How can it be that? He's a
corporate trainer, comedian and keynote
speaker based in New York.
Now, as a speaker,
he has delivered more than 500 talks in
front of 35,000 plus people.
His TED Talk, The Skill of Humor, has
nearly 9 million views. Woohoo! As an
author, he's written three best-selling
books including Humor That Works, The
Missing Skill for Success and Happiness
at Work.
Okay, let's get to it. Let's jump right
to it and start learning about various
types of humor. Now, I know that uh
friends, glad you're all here. Welcome.
Welcome, Stefan. Welcome. Welcome, Drew.
Welcome. Welcome, Veronica.
Now, I know for a fact you know, we hear
engineer, banking, financial planning
and our brains don't normally connect
humor right away. So, my first
unprepared question is this and I'll
begin with Veronica, then Drew, then
Stefan.
How in the round world does someone in
your industry end up being branded as
humorous, funny and comedian? Veronica,
I'll go to you first. Because
um people usually feel a little trauma
about their finances because they don't
understand that um when you're bad with
your finances, there's nothing wrong
with you. You're simply being human.
You know, our software has not been
updated in 40,000 years, Mark. So, if
you just throw some humor in there and a
little healing and forgiveness, it can
reframe their experience, touch their
hearts and their mind and revolutionize
full-time.
I love that. I don't think anyone here
will look at money the same way again.
Thanks. Drew, the humor engineer, help
us to connect engineering and humor,
please.
Certainly. Well, Mark, as a fellow
former computer programmer, maybe you
kind of can agree with this, but uh for
me as a computer science engineer, the
hardest resource I ever had to work with
was other human.
Uh I'm good with computers, not as good
with people and it turns out that in
some ways humor is a great kind of
shortcut or a great way to build better
rapport with humor. And And to your
point, I am not a naturally funny
person. If you ask people from my high
school
uh if I was a funny person or in fact
when they found out that I did comedy,
they're like, but
you're not funny.
So, I'm definitely one of those people
that had to learn how to use humor, but
as an engineer as I was learning that
skill, I was like, oh wait, this can
help me with the challenges that I'm
having at work and so that's how kind of
the humor and the engineering came
together.
That's awesome. Thanks, Drew. Thank you
so much. Now, Stefan,
a hot shot young banker on the rise to
the top and you leave that to be funny.
Help us to understand how that happened,
brother.
Well, when I went to quit, I told my
vice president, I quit and she's like,
is that one of your jokes? And I'm like,
I'm serious. I'm I'm quitting. And she's
like, are you going to the competition?
I'm like, no, to be a comedian. And they
wouldn't believe it. At the end of the
day, like Drew was saying, nobody
like my family thinks that I'm that
funny. Like my high school friends don't
think that I'm that funny. But like
everything, you can learn it. At the end
of the day, Yes.
there's different ways in which you can
see comedy, but in in in my research and
and and the books that I've I've read
and and the courses that I teach, it's
basically truth and pain. Mhm. Tragedy
plus time. Yes. Like the most beautiful
things in the world, they're not that
funny. In fact, we don't really like
people who are perfect. So the more
human you can be,
the better
the funny comes out, you know? It's it's
it's simple, but there has to be some
truth or some pain or some tragedy. And
when you're ready to talk about it, it
may be funny.
Well, you know, Stefan, I love that
thought. I'm going to bounce to you,
Veronica, and then back to you, Drew.
one this one. You said comedy fits with
pain.
And right now, with the world is,
well, there's a lot of pain out there.
Yes. How do you believe your brand of
humor really helps and fits into our
world now in these trying times? First,
Veronica, and then to Drew.
Well, I I love that question because um
as um as Stefan said that um when you
are in a lot of pain and there has been
a lot of transition with the the social
justice um our our politics, but that is
what makes it crucial for us to see the
light at the end of the tunnel. And
because we are um designed to look for
the humor. And it also it it makes us
healthier. It increases our endorphins.
Um it's so needed right now. And that is
why it's um it's just so important for
us to connect on that humanity level.
Thanks. Julia, response to that?
Well, as you said, these are
unprecedented times, which we know
they're unprecedented times because of
the unprecedented number of times people
have called them unprecedented times.
Um
but it is something that is particularly
valuable. And and as someone mentioned
already that, you know, there's a cliché
that says that comedy equals tragedy
plus time. And a lot of times people
take that as the idea that after enough
time has passed, we can find the comedy
in that tragedy, right? This is why I
can joke about being a super awkward
computer geek in high school because
enough time has passed that it's not
very real right now.
But what I found particularly true
during the pandemic is that the reverse
is almost true as well. It's if there is
something that tragic happens and we can
find the humor in it, it almost feels
like more time has passed. It says,
despite this adversity that has come up
or this challenge that has arisen, with
when we find humor in it, we can kind of
say, I'm laughing in the face of this
challenge. It's not going to control me.
It's not going to prevent me from doing
some other things that I want to do. And
that to me is where humor can become
really powerful because it can reframe a
situation so that you almost feel like
you have more control over it. I think
it's like as Drew said, I think it a
comedy is a way to heal um the pain of
all the things that are happening. And
um and it also lets us be exuberant and
joyful
um like we were as kids. And um and
especially when you bring that to
people's financial trauma. And I think I
kind of like
bless it with a little forgiveness and
we can move forward into the future um
with a better attitude. It's like
reframing. Wouldn't you say, Mark?
Well, you know what? You're right. You
said that reframing it. But you said
something else. You said it's like we
were as kids. I'm going to pivot on that
right now. I'm going to go to Stefan.
As a kid, did you think you were funny?
Were you told you were funny? And did
you plan, I'm going to be a banker
turned comedian one day?
Well,
very good question. I I didn't think I
was funny.
I had two big brothers, so I definitely
wasn't getting the last laugh at that
house or at in school. And I was the one
who laughed at everyone and everyone
else's jokes. And my laugh would make
people laugh. And I would get out of the
class because of my laughter. But uh
I wasn't particularly funny. And then my
observations as I as I was starting to
grow uh and and get older, my
observations would make people laugh.
And later in in my career, especially
when I started in Toastmasters, I found
that that I was funny. I just want to
take a couple seconds to agree with Drew
and and Veronica about the tragedy plus
time. It's almost like if you say it,
something that's painful, it Yeah, time
time goes by and it immediately doesn't
have power over you. Yes.
And and the perfect example is when I go
home to Costa Rica and my family or like
my grandma is like, oh, you've gained
some weight and you're balding. And I'm
like,
like I get super angry. But if I say it
first,
it's like it I'm like, yeah, I know I'm
fat and I'm balding. And they're like,
oh, like you said it before like before
me, you know? So
it doesn't have power over me if I say
it first.
Well, it's interesting here to hear you
you know, you all three are kind of
analyzing and explaining on a very
almost intellectual level how much fun
we can have with humor. But I would I
would guess there individuals listening
and watching today who may think, wow,
Stefan's on the cover of the magazine
and you know, Drew's got 9 million views
and Veronica's got Rodney Dangerfield's
last name, but I am not that funny.
Could you give us some really simple
ways we can make people smile? Is there
a formula to make people smile? I'm
going to go with Veronica cuz she got a
whole hand in the air. Me, me, me first.
Well, the thing is is that, you know, I
have a name like a superhero and also
Rodney Dangerfield's only black child.
But also,
my blood type is B positive.
Ooh. So you can take some personal
things about yourself and you can flip
them. Do you have a nickname that's
funny? You know, um can you claim
something? Because I personally can
claim I am the funniest woman in the
credit union world. There you go.
You own that. You see, you know, so so
it is is like having a sense of
entitlement and then claiming it. You
You have to commit to comedy like you
commit to love and a relationship. You
got to love comedy like you love a small
child. You got to be committed
committed, you got to be consistent, and
you can never give up. I love that. I
love that. Now, Drew,
I
can you top that? Simple ways that we
all, every people can be funny. Is there
a formula or what can we do to make
people smile every day?
Certainly. Well, I mean, it depends on
how much time we have to answer that.
First of all,
I want to give a shout-out to some of
the people in the chat because
apparently we're answering questions
very well. It feels very polished
because people are like, this is a
pre-recorded thing, right? It's like,
no, I can see you all typing in the
chat. Is this pre-recorded or is this
live? This is live. Totally live.
Shout-out to Eunice B Positive. Carla's
saying greetings from Guyana. Like we
can actually see what's going on there.
But to answer your question, I think
that um I think everyone has a sense of
humor. And so when it comes to
determining, are you funny, the real
question is, what kind of funny are you?
Are you? And there's different styles of
it. And I believe that there is an art
and a science to humor. And we can teach
you the science. We're more than happy.
Let's do a deep dive into what a comic
triple is and what we mean by setup and
punchline and what a callback is. And
like we can teach the science piece of
it. The art component of humor comes
from partially practice and repetition.
Going Toastmasters events, going to a
stand-up club, taking an improv class.
And it's also your sense of humor. It's
what you find interesting. And that's
where everyone's skill of humor starts
with is just kind of like, what makes
you go, huh? Mhm. That's interesting.
Huh, that's curious. And that's how you
start to develop that humor. So the
quick tip, you asked for a quick tip.
The first one that I will give you, one
that I'm sure that Stefan and Veronica
agree with, is to keep a humor notebook.
So that's mine right back there. You
keep one notebook where you take anytime
you have one of those ideas, like, huh,
that's an interesting thing. You write
it down in the humor notebook. Or if
something crazy happened to you, write
it down in the humor notebook. If you
break your arm, you like, well, go to
the hospital
have the nurse write down in the humor
notebook for you kind of about that
experience. And what that does is two
things. One, it helps you remember the
funny thing later because you're like,
if you sit down to try to be funny and
you're like, huh, this thing that I
thought of it happened to me in the
shower to this morning where I thought
of this funny thing. I didn't write it
down right away. And now I'm like, I
know exactly where I was standing. I
know how the wind was coming in through
the window, how the light was shining.
Can't remember what the idea was. So you
write the idea down. The second thing
that writing stuff down does is it
changes your perspective. You start to
notice the funny things in the world
around you simply by doing it a little
bit more. And you realize just how many
opportunities there are for a little bit
of humor.
Oh, wow. Very very good idea. You know,
it's funny. I've been teaching speaking
for a long time. And I have a one tip
finding good stories. I asked my clients
to to look over go back over your day
and ask yourself this question these
questions. What amazed you? What amused
you? And what moved you?
So write it down and then ask yourself
what can I learn from that?
And I I think you know you've talked
about Drew you break your arm.
One of you can laugh at yourself your
name you know I've got this place and
Stefan you said you were a little kid
and you'd laugh and your laugh made
people laugh. And there's a general rule
central theme there where at some point
you all use what we call
self-deprecating or self-depreciating
humor. Stefan could you explain to us a
little bit what that means and how it
works in for you certainly in your in
your comedy style?
100%
I'm I'm big on self-deprecating humor
and and I think most comedians or first
of all most comedians are introverts and
second of all it which a lot of people
don't expect and and second of all I
think the majority of people start with
self-deprecating humor because it's
accessible. It's it's
your physique it's your life and you've
had that self-awareness because as kids
in your family you got told stuff and
and people tell you things about the way
you look or the way you sound. So
one of the ways that I use it is in
things that have bugged me in the past
or things that are horrible stereotypes.
I just use it and distort the the
pressure I just release the pressure
people can laugh. And it's funny. So
like for example
sometimes I open my shows with
um hi my name is Stefan Dyer and I'm
Costa Rican or as most people call us
Mexican and and
and and that's the thing like if you
speak Spanish in North America people
think you're Mexican. So it doesn't bug
me because I lived in Mexico and I I
love Mexicans. But some people may find
it offensive and I just take that use it
it releases the pressure it
it gets people to laugh and now we can
continue. So it can be your height your
hair your accent your face whatever it
is that makes you different chances are
you could get a laugh with that.
Uh Veronica yeah follow up question for
So I um I started my comedy because I
was when I was a little girl I wasn't
raised in the United States. I was
raised in Tokyo Japan um from 5 to 10
years old. And I went from Tokyo Japan
to East Texas
where um I did a lot of things wrong cuz
I hadn't been black for all that long.
Uh but uh
but um but because of the I was
ostracized because I didn't speak
um because um we had a language problem
because nobody in Texas spoke English.
Um
but um but because of that because of
the trauma that I had as a child it
allowed me to take um something that was
probably pretty devastating and turn it
into comedy. Mhm. You know because I was
an outsider
and um
and uh and that was my introduction but
all of us have funny stories from our
childhood and and as you as uh as Stefan
and and Drew talked about um write them
in a in a journal and then practice
them. Yeah.
You know to just pick random people and
tell them the story and see if they
laugh.
And then you can you can you can twerk
the language a little bit and you can
get it to where it'll work all the time
cuz when you have one good joke I'm
telling you
it doesn't it never gets stale. Yeah.
You know both you and Drew mentioned I'm
going to get to you I'm going to get to
your response real quickly Drew. I want
to reiterate all of us can practice and
you don't have to go to a comedy club on
an open mic night. I discovered I could
practice on my family. Yes.
They'll laugh at me a lot but at least
my kids will say dad that was really
really bad. Great it just might land
then. But don't you have a Toastmasters
club? Use Toastmasters club. Use your
family but try things out test them and
people don't need to know you're guinea
pigs. Drew your comment. Yes I have two
things just a very quickly build off of
that is yeah so you know that in terms
of the the workshops that we do we talk
about a couple of different comedic or
comedy tools comedian tools. Humor
notebook is number one. Number two for
us is the stage right? Every comedian
will tell you nothing beats stage time.
Uh but also Shakespeare said all the
world's a stage. So exactly to Mark's
point it doesn't have to necessarily
just be in a stand-up show. It can be
you know that's what I post to Twitter
is mostly just puns and the ones that
kind of like resonated or people
re-tweet I end up using a little bit
later. You can use it in conversations
and text messages with people. You can
join Toastmasters and groups. I think
that's an important point. But I want to
go back to self-deprecating just for a
moment because one it's an incredibly
powerful form of humor especially when
you are in a high status position. So as
speakers there's an automatic status
that comes with it. So certainly that's
where humor is helpful where you can you
know I'll talk about I'm a frail person.
I was born 8.3 pounds and then stayed
that way till I was 15 years old.
All right?
So it's like oh he's very skinny. So
that's that's valuable but there are
some limitations to self-deprecating
that I think is valuable to to recognize
particularly in the use of humor between
men and women. So in one study if we're
talking about in the context of the
workplace they found in one study that
uh when men use humor in the workplace
they were met with a positive response
around 80% of the time. Positive
response being a smile or a laugh. Uh
when women use humor in the workplace
they were met with a positive response
20% of the time. And so that's a very
big gap. In that same study they found
that 90% of the humor that men used was
off-the-cuff conversational type humor.
The uh women they 70% of the time they
used self-deprecating humor. And so
again self-deprecating humor great when
you're in a high status position and
when used sparingly. Cuz you might know
those people if you only use
self-deprecating humor unless you're
Rodney Dangerfield which built like an
entire career off of it. But for the
most part in a workplace setting people
start to wonder like wait does this
person have self-esteem issues? Can I
actually still laugh or is that actually
a bad thing? Like is this a pity party?
What's going on there? And if there is
gender bias in the workplace and status
is already perceived to be a little bit
lower for whatever reason then the use
self-deprecating humor it only lowers
that status a little bit more. So again
incredibly powerful when in a high
status position. I just want to make
sure that we're not saying go all in on
self-deprecating user humor only use
that. It's like no it's a great way to
start so that people know that you have
a sense of humor but then from there you
can move to other types. Well one good
point you make is be aware of what your
audience hears what your audience sees
and what they're thinking because their
perception it could backfire. Now don't
get all don't get all scared people. We
want to have fun and I want to go into
the idea of being being in the workplace
and also as speakers and presenters
because this is what we do at
Toastmasters we talk to people. But in a
workplace setting you know even in
interviews is there a role Stefan for
people to use humor in a workplace in
being a job interview do you think?
I think it's always good to to use it
you you got to be really aware of the
situation.
It it may serve you well but at the same
time which is a feedback that I got at
the beginning of my career in the bank
I would make everyone laugh so much that
one day like my boss who I really
appreciate his name was Dave he came up
to me and he was like with our team
do that it's okay to make us laugh but
in front of executives and everyone in
the senior meeting they think you don't
care like you're indifferent you're just
having a good time making everyone laugh
and it might be misinterpreted
that you don't you're not serious about
your job. And obviously there's some
cultural nuances and you have to be
aware of what country you are you're at.
Like in Latin America it may be very
normal to joke around all the time. But
in North America there's times where you
do it times where you don't do it even
in Latin America. So I think it's very
useful to at times break the ice like
Drew said if you're not in a high status
because it allows people to relax
position yourself as hey I'm just one of
the guys you know
you can be normal and when people are
not intimidated you you tend to work a
lot better and and one of the quotes
that I love is that relationships move
at the speed of vulnerability and it's
hard to be vulnerable when everyone is
just trying to be like super perfect. So
humor is a great way of just
uh
getting everyone to laugh release the
tension and now we can move on to the
next stage get down to business. So you
can use it in interviews and and in the
workplace but just be aware of the tone
and the vibe of the situation.
Thanks.
I find it I find it great as a teaching
tool
um because when you um can take a
complex um topic that might be very
traumatic for people and um put a
blanket of
a a humor around it it it makes people
relax you can connect and it also gets
them and and it's all it's also very
fast. So if I can connect with them
through humor then I can get right to
the teaching of the different behaviors
that can liberate them and give them
quality thoughts and a quality life um
through love cuz I think that humor is a
form of love.
I love that and I want to I want to let
Drew
respond to that but I also want to ask
because now we're Toastmasters we have
been able to travel the world from our
chairs through doing virtual meetings.
So, internationally, Drew, if you've
done any talking internationally, what
are some of the concerns you have or
cautions for us who are now getting a
chance to speak on different continents
right here from our desks regarding
humor and understanding cultural nuance.
Any thoughts on that for you, Drew?
Drew, and then Stefan.
Certainly. So, the the way that we frame
things, cuz I'm an engineer, I like kind
of like the the specificity of things.
The way that we frame using humor in the
workplace is what we call our humor map.
Uh and this is the final
It's It's been pretty good. So, when we
think of the scale of humor on our side,
we think of sense of humor, which you
can build by using your humor notebook,
your ability to humor, which you get
better at by getting on the humor stage,
and the third piece is your agency with
humor, your application of humor. And
this you can develop by using what we at
least frame as a humor map, which stands
for your medium, your audience, and your
purpose. And so, we've talked a lot
about that audience piece. Absolutely,
you have to
who's going to be listening. What are
they going to actually find funny? What
do What do they want? What does that
audience need? What do they expect so
that you can give give them what they
need in a way maybe that they don't
quite expect. To your point, Mark,
virtual changes the medium, and it's
very different to present in a virtual
setting than in a uh in-person setting.
One quick tip I would give is, and I
learned this from Mark Bowden, a great
um body language expert, is to put a
little smiley face right next to your
webcam or googly eyes if you need to,
but that way you're constantly checking
in with the webcam cuz that's what eye
contact versus like looking at yourself
the entire time.
Also, like frame your video. You don't
want to do what like some people do
where they do what I call the turtle.
Yeah, kill the camera. Or the the
Batman.
Understand your mute button. You don't
want to
I'm good with that.
So, understand the medium that you're
going to do it. And then the last one,
the one that I think is most important
to Stefan's point and also some people
in the the chat who are saying like,
"Yeah, sometimes I'm not taken
seriously." The most important is the
purpose. Is why are you using humor in
the workplace setting? Because the goal
is not to be seen as a comedian. It's
not to be like, "Oh, that person is so
funny." But it's to get better results.
And so, when you use humor not to
replace the work, but to enhance it.
When you use humor like, "Oh, I'm going
to start with a story people are
actually listening and paying attention
to what I've said." Or "I'm going to use
an association so that they understand
that idea a little bit better." Or "I'm
going to add a little bit of incongruity
so I can like perk people up a little
bit as I go longer and longer as I
speak." Like those reasons
all help to create humor that is not
only funny, but also effective toward
the larger goal.
Uh that's a good wonderful answer.
Giving some good technique, being aware
of who we are, where we are, what
environment is. Both you and Stefan
mentioned that. I'm going to jump to
Stefan very quickly about the little
deeper on the idea of having
international audiences. And you you do
humor in two different languages. You
know, you do Spanish and English. I have
I speak in two languages. I speak
English and and poor English. But when
you have audiences that are
international, cross-cultural,
what are the cautions you would have for
us who now have this medium of
Toastmasters worldwide, we can try to be
funny to an audience in Saudi Arabia or
China or Korea. What do we look out for,
Stefan, and then Veronica's as well?
Uh it's it's an art. I tell you, you
have to be
very very aware of who you're talking
to. Knowing your audience is almost half
the battle. And I And I would say
my audience is the immigrant audience.
That's my favorite audience because I'm
an immigrant myself. So, when I'm there,
I can go hard and I know that certain
people, because we're all immigrants,
especially
in Spanish, Latinos, they may not get
offended if I say this or that. Or or
they may get offended if I say this or
that. Or if I speak to an all
Anglo-Saxon audience or or all white
audience in Canada, I may not have jokes
where I they're the victim of the joke
that much, you know? But if I'm only
talking to Latinos, maybe yeah. And one
of the things that we say in comedy is
that
not necessarily safe, but
smart to do this is that you always
punch up. Don't punch down at people who
can't defend themselves or or are
already the victims. Like if if um
a politician has abused his or her
power, and I punch up because they're in
power, that's okay. Nobody's going to
get that angry. But if I punch down
towards
a demographic that has been typically
abused for for years or decades, that's
not funny. Like that you're just
punching down, that's not that funny.
So, you have to you have to be very
aware and understand the cultural
differences of who you're speaking to.
So, um
and it the it comes with
practicing as well. Like it It's not
like you wake up one day and you're
really good at it. The other thing that
that happens is that the more you
practice, you understand you get that
really good self-awareness of what
people actually find funny about you and
your life, not what you think is funny
about you and your
They This is the audience.
So, the more you do it, you get greater
self-awareness about what people
actually like and what you're good at.
So, it becomes your style and not you
trying to imitate someone on TV or on
Netflix.
Veronica?
I I I agree 100%. And what my
my persona is is that
I try to come at my audience with love
and acceptance and grace.
And and I use humor to connect. So,
hopefully, if they get an understanding
of who I am and where I'm coming from,
that kind of
it gives us all an equal equal playing
ground because I am one of you and I am
on your team.
And I am coming to support you in living
your best life because that's what I
want to do, Mark. I want to perform a
comic miracle and have you reframe how
you look at things so that you're
happier.
And and hopefully, I'm successful, but
that's always the goal.
Well, I love that answer cuz that gives
me a nice setup. Drew, I'm going to go
with you first, then Veronica and
Stefan. A question for each of you.
What was it like? Have you ever
bombed, Drew?
Uh which time would you like me to talk
about? There's
so Last Tuesday?
Last Tuesday, yeah. Well, how recent do
you want to go?
But actually, so there is um and I think
the stories in the bombing are actually
particularly helpful. So, to your point
about an international audience, a
couple of years ago, I was in Singapore
speaking, and I'd never been to
Malaysia. So, I was like, "Maybe I can
go to Malaysia and I can do stand-up
comedy." So, I got booked on an
English-speaking stand-up show in
Malaysia, Kuala Lumpur. And I go, and I
was relatively early in the comedian in
the lineup cuz I was a new addition. And
I go up, and it's relatively crickets as
I am performing. And I come off stage,
and I'm like, "You know what? Maybe
maybe they're just one of those
audiences that doesn't express their
laughter out loud." Cuz sometimes you
have that. Like sometimes you'll speak
for a group, and there will be no
laughter whatsoever, and then they'll
come up after you very stone-faced and
be like, "That was a great greatest
presentation I've ever seen." And of
course, the cliché that we say in the
speaking industry is like, "Tell your
face
if you're enjoying the experience, tell
your face so that we can see that."
That's particularly true in a virtual
environment. Have your videos on and
have people laugh so they can get that.
But so, like maybe it's one of those
audiences. The guy after me goes up, and
he
crushes it. He was like as if like, you
know,
Dave Chappelle like level like funny or
whatever. The audience loved it. And I
realized, and one of his funniest jokes
was actually a callback to a joke that I
tried to make. He just did it better.
Which was like, he's clearly like now
messing with me. Like he knows he's very
good.
But the thing that I recognized from
that was I didn't understand my
audience. It was my first time doing
comedy in Asia, in Malaysia. And I
assumed what worked in Europe, like when
I've done presentations and stuff in the
UK and Germany and other places, I took
some of that same material and assumed,
"Oh, it's international. They'll like
all the international stuff." And I
hadn't done my my homework. And And what
I've found for myself as I've presented
more internationally is, especially as a
speaker, there's three things that have
really helped. One, slowing down.
I I like to speak really fast, and for
people with English as a second
language, sometimes it takes a moment,
and you need a little bit longer of a
pause so that you don't step on your
laughter.
Two,
is using more stories because people can
identify with stories. Mark and I were
joking before this. Like I love puns. Uh
and this for for the fellow puns lover
pun lovers out there, my you know, a
recent pun that I really enjoyed on that
was originally just posted on LinkedIn
was, "If you started dating someone
online, and then you break up, that
person just becomes your web app."
Boom boom. Well, yeah, exactly. Little
pun there, but might not be for
everyone. So, not puns, but more
stories. And then the last thing that we
can really use as speakers is I love
visuals. So, I use a lot of pictures in
my presentations. I embed them in my
video itself. And pictures you know,
speak a thousand words. You don't have
to speak any language to be able to see
an interesting or humorous picture and
have a connotation to it right then. So,
that's kind of what I've learned from a
recent bombing. And it yes, it still
happens. Happens less and not as bad as
it used to, but there's always something
to be learned when it happens.
Thank you, Stefan.
Uh it's part of the journey, Mark.
It always happens and and you just have
to show up.
I mean, like Drew said, now it happens a
lot less than my first year.
And now I understand I always arrive
early, always. See the audience, see the
table.
I start talking a little bit of people.
I start seeing how they're reacting. I
start seeing there's like weird things
in the audience or not like crazy weird
stuff, but like if there's a table of of
10 10 girls and and one guy or if
there's like a table of of of eight
grandparents or if there's a a one
person by themselves or all these things
are
info that I can use and to reduce a
little bit my
um
my chances of of failing, what I do is
cuz I feel like if you go hard with the
first joke at the beginning, it's it's
high stakes. Like if that doesn't land,
it's down downhill from there. So, what
I do is I start with like one-liners
which are short jokes and I start having
a conversation with the audience just to
understand them a little bit and crowd
working with them. Then I start seeing
okay and the stakes are not high when
you're talking to the audience cuz it's
just conversation. Like it's not like I
go and like
and nobody laughs, you know? It's It's
just a conversation. So, I'm not really
risking anything.
You always have to go back on the
drawing board even if you do really well
or really horrible and in your humor
notebook, write what happened, what went
well, what didn't go well, and I always
record myself. And it's painful
video. Like horrible because you think
you sometimes did better than you
actually did. But you it's where I've
learned the most about me.
And and that's what I always do. I go
back to the video, see what worked and
what didn't. So, bombing is always an
opportunity.
Well, you know what? Recording is easy.
Watching is hard.
So, Veronica, have you ever bombed and
what did you learn?
I I got heckled one night in a comedy
club
by a dog.
So, that's all I'm going to say about
that.
The dog went crazy. It did not like the
joke and it would not shut up. But then,
the good news was the whole night was
about the dog heckling.
So,
you couldn't get a better joke after
that. There was just
It was just That was just there. So.
Well, what you and Stefan and Drew just
told me is use your failure as material
for later presentations. Now, our time
is fast fleeting. I want to get to one
more question specifically regarding
Toastmasters. As a speaking coach, I
have several clients who come to me,
Mark, I've got this great speech. Now,
all I want to do is add humor. What are
your thoughts on adding humor versus
uncovering humor? Stefan, Veronica, and
then Drew. Very quickly. Short question.
Your thoughts on on on uncovering versus
adding humor. Stefan.
So, it's it's always great to add humor.
What I would recommend is
putting the main premise of your speech
in the middle
and doing bubbles around it of where the
pain points are of whatever you're
presenting.
And where the pain points are, there's
chances that there's going to be humor
around it. So, not everything is going
to have humor about your speech, but if
you focus on the top three parts of
whatever you're presenting that has the
most pain around it,
chances are you could get some laughter
because you're going to create some
tension when you mention it and then
release it by being your by being
vulnerable, by saying where you've
messed up, by by telling a story.
Anything that connects with the audience
through pain points may get you a laugh,
but the tonality is incredibly
important. That's why you have to
practice. Practice. Practice.
So, Veronica, I shouldn't just go find a
joke I saw on Reader's Digest or on
Twitter somewhere and put that in my
speech?
Well, I I think that um
um if you if it's naturally if you can't
find the humor, if you have a funny
friend and you tell them the story, um
get some support around that. There's
I have quote books on humor
and I I love to watch comedy shows. In
fact, I make laughter a part of my daily
activity. I'm I do not go to bed until I
have a good laugh. So, with all that
infusion, it will support you on making
having a fun life, having a funnier
life, and making what your your
communications funnier. Thank you. And
Drew?
Absolutely. So, the way that I think
about adding humor to a a speech is
there's there's three ways to do it in
my kind of perspective. The first is
that you write something from scratch.
And uh that's actually the hardest one.
Like you you go through and you're like,
let me create a specific humor moment
exactly like right now from nothing. And
to me, that is difficult. It's possible
to do. There's certain exercises and
things that you can do, but it's the the
hardest cuz you suffer from the paradox
of choice a lot of time. The second way
is to take something that is already
funny and see how it can fit into your
program. Now, certainly for larger
speaking, sometimes that can be, you
know, you don't always have to be the
creator of humor. Sometimes you can be
the curator of humor and bring in other
things or even the funny stories. Like
if there's a story that you tell your
friends and family and they always crack
up about or uh there's, you know,
something that happens and you've
already created funny, you can look at
it and be like, okay, what are the
lessons in this story and how do they
apply to what I'm talking about? Right?
If you've seen my TEDx talk, I do a bit
on math pickup lines. That existed
before I did that talk, but I realized,
oh, math pickup lines and using them in
a bar is kind of like needing to be
confident. Oh, this is also true in
humor. So, now I can bring the thing
that I already know is funny and good, I
can bring into my speech. The third way,
the way that we do the most work with a
lot of the the people that we work on
one-on-one with is to take something
that is unfunny and make it funny.
And there's a couple of techniques that
we use. That's where I talked about kind
of the science piece of it. Like, for
example, if you are trying to make a
concept funny. If you have to explain
something, you're talking about your
strategy for stress management or
whatever it happens to be and you want
to make it funny, you can create an
association. I love this writing
exercise called a 10 by 10 matrix where
you write down 10 things related to the
specific thing that you are training and
then 10 things related to a passion that
you have. Like one passion, one hobby,
or something that the audience is going
to enjoy. Write 10 down 10 10 things
related to that and you'll start to
notice are there connections between the
two? So, can I explain stress management
while talking also about Queen's Gambit
or Bridgerton or golf or running? And
that inherently makes it more
interesting because you've now created a
great metaphor association and you can
make humor about the thing you're
associating with and still keep the
topic a little bit more serious or on
point if that's needed.
Wow, Drew, Stefan, and Veronica, so much
wisdom. I took notes. Have a daily
laugh. Know your audience. Use images.
Use self-deprecating humor. Have a humor
notebook. Record and review. Rehearse.
Find the pain. Gain support from a
friend and so much more. I want to thank
you all for the wisdom you've given us
today. I'm going to return control to
Linda because we have several questions
that have come in. I'm going to sit back
and drink in the wisdom. Linda, over to
you.
Thank you so much, Mark. And I was
taking notes as well.
Everyone, the insights, stories,
fantastic tips, just helping us all find
our funny, not trying to be somebody
else. So, I I
I want to hear more from all of you. So,
let's shift right into the question and
answer portion of our program and find
out what else our audience has been
asking about.
I'm going to start. We've tried to put
some of the categories together. I'm
going to start with um Stefan.
We talked a little bit about audience
and we've a few questions related to
tips for international audiences. So,
Ruth asked, do you have any tips for
international audiences, especially what
not to do?
And I know you touched all of you
touched on a few things. And then, are
there any easy go-to humor topics that
transcend cultures? Lisa wanted to know.
Stefan.
100%. Thank you, Linda. So, two things
off the top that are safe, never
religion, never politics,
unless you're sure that demographic has
the your views of the joke, but I still
wouldn't recommend it because it's a
gamble. So, what I what I would
recommend is
oh um if your story is yours and your
point of view is yours, then even if
people disagree, it may be funny because
you are the victim of the joke. So,
self-deprecating humor in cultural
scenarios is is great because
like for example, in in Latino like
there's a Latino stereotype where like,
oh, because of Narcos and whatever that
there's drug lords and everyone's a drug
lord. And I take that and turn it
negative into positive and I say, well,
I'm an eternal immigrant. I'm from I was
born in Costa Rica. I've lived in Peru,
Mexico, El Salvador, Montreal, and
Toronto, all because of my dad's job. My
dad's a drug lord, and and I and I and I
use that, and I'm the victim. Like I My
dad is the drug lord. So, nobody's like,
"Oh, they He said that I'm a No, I am
I'm making fun of myself and that
stereotype. So, understand
people's views, and the way you can do
it is one, asking the organizer who's
going to be there, what type of people
or industry, audience, countries, ages.
If they don't know, always arrive early
and talk to people, see who they are.
And if you can't do that because you're
in the green room, then live, you can do
that as well by going, "By show of
hands, who here is in marketing? By show
of hands, who here is in university?"
So, you can do that real in real time
yourself. And and it works really well.
Thanks, Stefan.
Uh I'm sure that everyone has even more
tips on that, but I want to make sure we
cover a few topics. So, I'm going to go
to Veronica next.
All of you talked a little bit about
comedy equals tragedy plus time, and and
things that were painful in the past.
But Kelly asked specifically, "How do we
make painful funny?" And someone else
also asked,
"Why are things that are supposed to be
sad, like COVID-19, sometimes funny?"
So, Veronica, could you address that?
Yeah, I think that um
this speaks to the complexity of the
human brain. That um when we um actually
experience something, and we really
understand it, um the point of um the
funny part of it is the part where we
start to heal from it.
Um
So,
um I think I think it is it's more of a
brain function and how comedy works. Cuz
comedy does take the tragedy and and the
present moment, and um and in the
present moment, you can laugh because in
the present present moment, typically,
there is no suffering. You are in the
moment, and it's funny.
So, um
So, that's how it is. It's one of the
wonderful things about being a human. We
um we have a very complex brain, and it
seeks to heal. And I think that's where
humor comes in.
Yeah, and I would just add one quick
addition to that is there's a great Kurt
Vonnegut quote that says, "Laughter and
tears are equal responses to
frustration." I myself prefer to laugh
because there's less cleaning up to do
afterwards. Yeah. And so, sometimes it's
a perspective shift. It's saying, "Okay,
this thing happened. I can't control
whether or not it happened," something
like COVID-19, "but I can control my
response to it, and can I find either
the humor in it?" Or and sometimes this
is where gratitude comes in. I love the
question of, "What's not wrong with my
life?" Not what's great about my life,
but what's not wrong with my life. And
that helps you to start to see while
there are a lot of challenges, things
that are tough, it helps you to start to
identify some of the things that aren't
so bad. Great perspective.
Great. Thank you. Well, Drew, I'm going
to stick with you now. We're talking
about laughs, and quite a few people
have asked about virtual presentations,
etc. versus live.
So, how do you stay motivated as the
presenter or the speaker during a
workshop like this when you can't hear
the audience? And you mentioned a few
things, some of you already, but you
know, normally we get energy from the
laughs. And is there anything else you
can um add about making virtual
presentations, you know, more humorous?
Absolutely, it's a great question. A
couple of things that we recommend as
we're doing coaching with virtual
trainings or things that I do as well.
One is in smaller groups, when we're
doing our virtual stand-up shows or if
we're doing something that's, you know,
probably 100 or less people, we'll
encourage and have some people unmute
their microphones if they have a quiet
background, so that we can hear that
laughter. And that's something that you
can do as a person setting up the event,
how to do that. The other thing is that
we strongly encourage people to have
their videos on, so that even if you
can't hear the laughter, you can kind of
see the head noddings and the smiling.
And we'll make a joke about it cuz not
everyone wants their video on, and so a
lot of times I'll say, you know,
"Seeing a lot of people that don't have
their video on, I'll admit I'm always a
little bit of skeptical of people who
have their video off. It's like, what
are you trying to hide? Is it, you know,
a bad hair day? Are you stuffing your
face with food? Do you have an
embarrassing like Backstreet Boys poster
on your wall? Like, what is it?" And
just adding humor to it, calling it out,
tends to bring in a few more people that
are like, "All right, fine. I'll
actually put my video on." So, we
encourage that to see it. But I think
the best tip that I can give is just
assume that you are crushing it. Yes.
Right? As you are presenting, just
assume that you're nailing it because to
have any other mindset, to have like,
"Are they laughing? I don't know."
doesn't actually help you to perform
better. That's why you record it, you go
back and improve a little bit later, but
in the moment, just assume that they're
laughing at every single joke, that it's
completely landing, and that I think can
be a strong kind of piece to to get you
to perform what you need to perform in
order to to deliver the humor in a way
that people resonate with. And along
with that is
um I actually laugh at my jokes because
it gives my audience time to actually
respond to the joke because then I'm not
going to run over it. And also, I think
I'm very funny. So, I keep the the
joviality going, you know? It's like,
"Yes, this is funny, and I am fun, and
we will laugh now."
You mean don't bring my wife in and make
her sit behind the camera and make her
laugh for me? That won't work?
It does work. You can also you can also
do a laugh track with you. I've I've
like done that as a joke as a presenter.
If you all don't laugh, I'm going to use
a laugh track button, and I think I'm
way funnier than you probably do. So,
every 3 seconds, it's going to be like
sitcom.
Yay, Drew. You can encourage the chat as
well. Like, that's another thing. At the
beginning, we'll encourage people use
the chat. A simple LOL or a haha or your
own thoughts does help to resonate with
the speaker so that they know that
they're getting some type of feedback.
Great. Thank you.
Mark, you're not off the hook. I'm I'm
going to give a question to you.
Okay. Any tips on how to be funny or
keep a sense of humor both in a
stressful situation as well as when
you're personally scared of of coming
across as awkward or or sounding like
you're forcing the humor. Any tips
around that?
You know, life is stressful, and I go
back to what Stefan said. If I realize
that my life and my experience can cause
the audience to relax and and and laugh,
I'll turn to my own self-depreciation
first because I think if I can get them
to laugh at me, then they'll relax and
see I'm a regular guy. I'm not some
superstar. I'm human. I want to have fun
with life. So, I turn it on me first,
and it also relaxes me. And I believe if
we can get people to laugh,
it's not just funny for the moment, but
it's funny for our lives. We can we can
experience some joy together. It's a
it's a common connector. So, laugh at
me, laugh at myself, and let's move on.
That's my technique.
Thank you, Mark.
Beautiful.
Yes.
So, Stefan, I know you mentioned that
you joined Toastmasters not realizing
you were funny. So, I'm going to send a
question from Sherry, who is also a
Toastmaster and is asking about her
club. She says, "Our club is wanting to
interject some humor, good feelings, and
fellowship into our virtual meetings. I
am not by nature funny or comfortable
telling jokes. So, I'm looking for any
suggestions on how to include humorous,
good feelings to our regular meetings.
Do you have suggestions?"
Uh so many. So, first of all, I myself
don't know any jokes. Like, I don't know
jokes. I just I just talk about my life.
Yes. I'm I'm vulnerable. I am I I tell
my truth, and I I share my tragedies, my
pain points. And and and by being honest
and candid, it I started to get people
to laugh with me or at me, I don't know,
at the beginning. But I immediately went
into the humor path and started to learn
about that as soon as I I
Even when I was like serious speeches, I
would get laughs, and I didn't
understand why.
So, I started reading, I started taking
workshops, I started taking the the
humor path, and listen and read all the
feedback you get. And when you when you
establish the rules of the game, even
for for virtual presentations, like Drew
said, it's it's
it works wonders because if you tell
people, "Listen, I want to get I want to
start getting more laughs. Can you give
me tips or what you thought was funny
about my presentation?" then you get
that self-awareness about what people
think that's funny about you, not what
you think is funny. And when you say,
"I'm going to tell you a really funny
story," don't say that because then
people expect like the best story. And
Just just be yourself, and
understand and get that self-awareness
from people. At at the same time,
I
I like to say that yes, experience is
the best teacher, but it's also costly.
So, if you want to just like fail on
stage and and
for 9 years until you become really
good, then okay, do it. But if you can
get really good
while getting on stage, whatever your
stage is, and take workshops, read
books, get feedback, then maybe you'll
get really good in 5 years. So, yes,
experience on the stage is is the best
teacher, but you there's also like so
many resources in nowadays in 2021,
YouTube is great, too.
And one quick tip, very quickly. In
regular conversation, if you get any
kind of reaction, a chuckle, a smile, or
a breakout laugh, make There you go,
Drew. Write that down. What did I just
say? What made them laugh? Because
sometimes we have humor and we don't
even know it. Yes. Linda.
Humor is like falling in love with a
child. You got to be consistent, you got
to be committed, and you should never
give up.
Fantastic.
Well, perfect timing.
Unfortunately, our time is up for our
question and answers. And thank you so
much, Mark, Stefan, Veronica, and Drew
for spending this time with us together.
It has just been
fantastic.
Um members of the audience, if you
enjoyed today's session, please register
right away as we're running out of room
for tomorrow's webinar, the humor
workshop part two.
Find out why laughter is the best
medicine and how to hone that healing
power of humor that Veronica mentioned
today, as well as our other panelists.
And as I mentioned, we will be sending
the recording of today's workshop to
everybody who registered, whether you
were able to attend today or not.
And please feel forward to fo-
I can't talk today. Feel free to forward
too many F's to your friends,
colleagues, et cetera, who you think
will benefit from the insights of our
connoisseurs of comedy.
And thank you everyone for joining us
today. We wish you a wonderfully
whimsical and hopefully humor-filled
rest of your day.
Thank you, Mark. Thank you all. It was
fun.
Thank you. Thank you all.